primero explicamosle a los televidentes
Qué significa esto de desplegar armas
nucleares en belarus qué supone una
medida de este tipo
Buenas noches aquí desde España pues lo
que significa es que es una escalada
militar del punto de vista geopolítico a
la respuesta que ha tenido
Europa o digamos la otan de incorporar
armas nucleares en lo que son los
límites geopolíticos de Rusia Rusia se
considera legitimada para incorporar
armas nucleares o otro tipo de
dispositivos como misiles hipersónicos
en la que son las fronteras de sus
alianzas militares en este caso
Bielorrusia no se considera que están
dentro de aceleración rusa son aliados y
Por tanto se considera que también es
una obligación en virtud de las alianzas
que tienen Rusia y Bielorrusia Pues de
defenderla como como participe o
participe de esta Alianza Y esto es lo
que ocurre ahora a partir de ahí veremos
la escala siguiente ahora en qué se
diferencia esta medida del armamento
nuclear que Estados Unidos tiene
almacenado en varios países de Europa
en absolutamente nada no se diferencian
nada los misiles que ha desplegado Rusia
en Bielorrusia pueden armarse con
cabezas nucleares o no al igual que los
misiles tácticos que tienen Polonia que
tienen la frontera con Rusia por ejemplo
son Igualmente misiles tácticos que
pueden ser armados con cabeza nuclear o
con cabeza convencional por tanto no se
diferencia absolutamente nada lo que sí
hay una pequeña diferencia es en la
diferencia de misiles como tales los
misiles que ha implantado Rusia su
misiles móviles como estamos viendo las
imágenes mientras que los misiles de la
parte de la otan están incorporados
dentro de lo que son bases militares
ahora Estados Unidos dijo ayer por
ejemplo que no había indicadores de que
Rusia se prepare para utilizar armas
nucleares estamos tal vez viendo una
medida de intimidación hacia occidente
no tanto una medida de intimidación como
una medida de planteamiento de sus
posiciones geopolíticas y
geoestratégicas seguimos de nuevo otra
vez pensando a la occidental en lugar de
pensar a la eslava y los eslavos piensan
del punto de vista doctrina militar que
mientras está habiendo un conflicto
político o este caso geopolítico esta
legitimados a seguir escalando
militarmente en lugar de desescalando
como parece ser que occidente piensa por
tanto no hay mucha diferencia respecto a
lo que ocurría hace un par de semanas la
única diferencia es que Rusia ha
planteado sus cartas geopolíticas a su
perspectiva y nada más